who doesn't enjoy john kerry
windsurfing in his buttock hugging lycra
is he windsurfing
to the upcoming climate summit in tahiti
or bali or wherever they're holding it
or will he be taking the old private jet
just to up his carbon credits joe
biden's climate czar
says he's confident he can work with
china
on persuading them to become carbon
neutral by 2060.
i believe they'll be uh uyga neutral
long before then
and let's face it on present course by
2060 there's not going to be anything
recognizable
as the united states so who cares bill
gates
is committed to as we discussed the
other night turning off the sun
which apparently can do for about a
billion bucks without any
government's permission i don't know why
we need to because
biden's epa administrator says the new
infrastructure bill which reclassifies
everything from a decaf macchiato to
your transitioning middle schooler
as quote unquote infrastructure that
bill
says the epa guy will apparently save
the climate just
another week in the wacky world of
climate change mark morano
is the author of green fraud why the
green new deal is far worse than you
think full disclosure i wrote the
introduction to the book
but the 300 pages that follow my intro
aren't uh aren't too shabby
mark it's great to see you i would have
thought after
a year of pandemic a year of economic
devastation
uh that climate change would be an
indulgence
uh the western world could no longer
afford but apparently
uh the lockdown has just been a kind of
warm-up act for what's coming
it really has exactly you would think
that this would be the lowest of all and
it actually is a very low priority even
the harris polling ceo said it's dropped
off the map
even among concerns of any americans i
mean it's dropped out of there but
not among government officials in the
progressive democratic party who rules
the country right now and what they've
done is they've been inspired and jane
fonda's words are
god's gift to the left was coveted
because of the lockdowns
and john kerry is excited specifically
because the lockdowns have crushed the
economy
and now they can rebuild it in a nice
green
image and that's what they're trying to
do with everything from domestic now to
these international meetings with china
yeah what's weird is that the
restrictions on liberty
are painted as somehow environmentally
friendly i saw some lunatic report on
the bbc that was my
first mistake switching on the bbc but
they were saying oh ireland has
managed to reduce its carbon footprint
because nobody's allowed to go more than
three miles from their home
think how spectacular that would be if
we cut it down
from three miles from your home uh to a
mile and a quarter
i mean this that's that's how they're
presenting it
yeah we look at that as insane
government overreach uh authoritarianism
but the left looks at it as
what an opportunity at first the climate
activists were jealous
of the coveted lockdowns if we can clock
down for a you know a virus we can do
the same thing for climate
but now they're inspired by it and we
actually have
uh everyone from greta thunberg to the
united nations officials to john kerry
himself he said the parallels are
screaming at us between covet and
climate
so global emissions reduce seven percent
during the lockdown
and so the uk guardian the left-wing
newspaper is so inspired
they want to lock down every other year
and you know what we could meet our u.n
climate goals if only we did a lockdown
every other year according to the paper
uh you mentioned the polls why don't we
yeah and i
i get that the polls say this is number
37 in our priority
of everything but why are people
reluctant to actually
laugh out loud at john kerry and co with
this i mean
when it when it comes up officially
people still well you know you remember
they don't they're not quite as scoffing
as they ought to be
it's a very good question uh and i think
part of the reason is
the media has been so effective in
academia at
censoring all the dissent out there you
know the whole 97 percent so the
public is sort of intimidated by this
and that's the whole point of the green
agenda
if you don't agree you are an evil
denier compared to a holocaust denier
it's all about dissent and so you feel
you feel as though you can't
legitimately dissent and that you know
but then you see you know the uh what
they're doing and i think we're going to
see a growing massive dissent when the
american public realizes both
domestically and internationally what's
happening now on climate
yeah if you think the uh the flatulent
bovines of aoc's nightmare
make a lot of noise you should wait
until the american people understand
what things like that infrastructure
bill and the
next climate summit are going to do
thank you thank you so much
for that mark and great to have that
book out
green fraud it's available now